- That's Nina in the morning!
- [Evan] That's Nina in the morning?
(exclaims) Scary!
We're goin' to Disney!
- Who said that?
- Alright.
(thunder rolling)
(glass shattering)
(harp and chimes flourishing)
- Good morning, good morning,
good morning, good morning.
It's day three.
That means, today is...
- Disney, and the rest of
the week, after Saturday.
It's Kids Day.
- [Evan] It's lots of Kids Days.
We got kids everywhere.
We are leading off with
some breakfast smoothie,
made to you, by Nina!
Look at that.
Now, it looks like yummy.
It is 7:30 in the
morning, and we are awake,
and ready to go,
because we're excited
that it's Disney Day!
We got, we got 25 minutes
to eat, and leave,
and crush some Disney!
- Good morning!
- Believe Nation!
- [Evan] We're goin' to Disney!
- Who said that?
- Alright.
- We're excited to go.
We're going to head off to
Epcot, have a great day.
How did you sleep, Nina?
- [Nina] Not that well.
- Not that well.
Well, you know what solves
a bad night's sleep?
- [Nina] Coffee.
- A very busy day.
That's the solution.
Just work a lot the next day.
(kids laughing)
- [Nina] That's really good advice.
(energetic rock music)
- This is it.
We're here.
Jeffrey's excited.
(Hayden exclaiming)
Hayden's excited.
Nina and Stephanie are back there.
Also excited.
I like how the sun looks
on my face right now.
It's coming in nicely.
That's where we're going.
Nina's very excited, why?
- My pokemon ran away.
- Oh, well that doesn't make her excited.
She's excited by all the new pokemon here.
We basically came to Disney,
so that the kids, and
Nina, can catch pokemon.
That's all Nina really cares about.
(Nina chuckling)
Right?
(mellow music)
It's Team Evan and Stephanie,
against Team Nina, Jeffrey, and Hayden.
Who's going to win?
- [Group] Me!
- Me!
- [Jeffrey] Me!
- [Hayden] Me!
- [Evan] Stephanie's
going to pick a fast one!
Wow!
Look at that car!
- I can't control it!
- [Evan] Finish drawing it, too.
That is a crazy car, Jeffrey!
(light mid-tempo music)
This is Stephanie and my car!
Boom, boom!
This is Hayden, and
Jeffrey, and Nina's car!
Boom, boom!
Let's see who wins!
Rocket ship car!
(mysterious electronic music)
(group screaming)
(energetic electronic music)
My hair was all over the place, guys!
(group laughing)
Okay, guys, how was that?
- Good, we lost!
- [Evan] Jeffrey's excited!
Nice!
- [Hayden] It's me and Nina!
With hair as the weapon!
- [Evan] Look at Nina's hair!
Look at Nina's hair!
Alright, next step,
we're going to go on the
brand-new Frozen ride!
Ride a boat through the land of Frozen.
So, let's see.
Here we go!
(relaxing mid-tempo music)
We got a great spot in line, Nina.
Good job.
(Nina chuckling)
Okay, so this line-up is crazy,
and Nina hasn't had her coffee yet.
So, we're going to kill
two birds with one stone.
While Nina waits in line,
I'm going to run back to the
entrance, and get her some coffee.
Here we go!
Alright, I made it!
With just a line-up
out the door here, too!
It's a day of line-ups today!
Alright, so Starbucks
was a 40-minute wait,
which means I'm going
to get back in the line.
So, I went to get the cafe coffee.
How is it?
- It's good coffee.
- Oh, that's nice.
Kids!
Who want a cookie?
- [Kids] Me!
- You have to share!
(Evan and kids exclaiming)
(light music)
(exclaims) Frozen ride!
Here we go!
(slow orchestral music)
How was it?
- Good, good good!
- [Hayden] Great!
- [Stephanie] I loved it!
- [Evan] You liked it, mister?
- [Hayden] Yeah!
- [Stephanie] So good!
That waterfall...
♫ For the first time in ♫
Alright, time to go get some lunch!
I'm going to run ahead, and order.
- That's Nina in the morning!
- [Evan] That's Nina in the morning?
(exclaims) Scary!
Nina in the morning is pretty scary!
(energetic music)
There's our lunch!
Fish and chips!
How is it?
Take a bite!
- Where will I put the ketchup?
- [Evan] How is it, mister?
- Good!
- [Evan] Good, Hayden, try something.
How is it?
- That's good.
- [Evan] Yummy, Stephanie?
Good, Nina, yummy?
Alright!
Time to eat.
Let's get serious.
- [Hayden] Where do I put the ketchup?
- I hope we got a belly full of food!
- Yes, I'm full!
- [Evan] Full?
Good.
We're going to go do
some soaring, and soar.
You know.
It's a fun ride.
It was closed last year.
We couldn't go on it.
So, Steph and Jeffrey have never been on!
And Hayden, I think, was
too small the first time.
So, nobody's been on, except Nina and I.
So, it'll be fun!
(quick energetic music)
We're here, inside Soaring.
We're about to get a tour of
what we're supposed to do.
Can't really see the screen.
Jeffrey's excited!
Nina's excited!
- Yeah, I'm going to
sit beside Uncle Evan.
- [Evan] Stephanie's excited!
I'm not your uncle, by the way.
And Hayden is excited!
So excited.
Look at that excited face.
(Evan chuckling)
Nina's excited, too.
I'm not allowed to film inside.
Sorry, guys, we'll see
ya on the other side.
Blast off!
Okay, how was it, guys?
- [Kids] Good!
- We're definitely going next year!
- [Evan] We're going next year?
- [Stephanie] Yes!
- It's cool, 'cause you can smell things,
when you see a good picture on the screen,
and then you get a nice
scent in your face.
We didn't have the orange
tree this year, though!
- [Nina] No, no, no.
Yeah, didn't have the orange this year.
- [Evan] No orange tree.
But, we got to smell a
bunch of yummy stuff.
The stand-by time is 100 minutes.
That's why you book
FastPasses and plan ahead,
so you don't wait in that line!
(light energetic music)
This is Nina.
- Hi.
- She's been very patient and happy today.
And I think she deserves
a Starbucks coffee.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
You see that excitement?
That's more exciting
than a ride, for Nina.
So, I've brought her to Starbucks.
Look at that, look at that timing!
So, Nina got her drink.
What'd you get?
- Caramel macchiato.
(Nina exclaiming and chuckling)
- Okay, let's find mine.
Oh, yeah!
The green tea.
Green tea is good for you.
This is 100 percent good for you,
because it's green tea, guys.
That's what I've learned.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's good. (exclaims)
Alright.
Next ride.
(mid-tempo calm music)
Next up!
Spaceship Earth!
FastPass!
- [Hayden] The pilot?
Do we each get a job?
- [Evan] No, we're going into the future!
- Yeah, future!
- Future!
- We've got to finish our
drinks, before we go in.
It's a lot of drink.
(mid-tempo calm music)
(exclaims) I have a brain freeze,
from drinking that drink so quickly.
Tongue is frozen!
But, it was good.
It was good.
Alright, and here we go.
(relaxing electronic music)
What am I most interested in?
Work.
"Where would you like
to work in the future?"
The city.
"What's your ideal work environment?"
The energy of an office.
"Where do you get your best ideas?"
Everywhere!
Thinking by myself.
"What's in your bag?"
Only what I need, guys.
Simplicity.
What describes you best?
I live to work, I work to live.
I live to work!
"How do you want to travel in the future?"
A car that drives
itself, or a hover train?
Let's go car that drives itself.
Nice.
Hey!
Look at that guy!
Look at that sexy guy!
- [Narrator] In the future,
the city will be a great place to work.
- [Evan] Nice!
Wow, look at my eyes.
- [Narrator] You're outfitted
with global networking,
and the latest digital tools,
to turn your dreams into a reality!
- [Evan] Who's that?
Board meeting?
Have to be, wow!
- [Narrator] Need to be somewhere?
No problem!
Just pack up and go!
- [Evan] Alright.
I'm a surfer.
Look at that car.
Nice.
I'm a happy guy in that car.
How was it?
- My bubble was so funny!
I'm like this.
And the closet, it tells
you what to wear everyday.
- [Evan] Okay.
- [Hayden] And also...
- [Evan] Are you going
to listen to the closet?
- You have five robots that
clean your room for you.
- [Evan] (exclaims) That's pretty cool.
So, in the future, I picked,
I'm usually with somebody.
So, we should pick, we
should pick life, right?
So, I was by myself, so I picked work.
And I said I liked the
energy of an office.
And then, it has me
working from the beach!
(Nina laughing)
I don't want to work on the,
I don't want to work on the beach, guys!
I don't want to work, I
want to work in an office,
and get stuff done.
I don't want to work from the beach.
What's work on the beach?
I want to work from an
office, and get stuff done.
I'm upset about my future.
You know what, I'm not going to
accept that future! (chuckles)
I'm going to make my own future!
Take that, Epcot future!
Going to make my own!
I get to work from an office,
and get lots of stuff done.
And I'm not making surfboards, either.
I'm making something
more valuable, impactful,
changing entrepreneur.
- Change time!
(Evan laughing)
(slow relaxing music)
- [Evan] Oh, Nina.
Hello.
- Hello.
- [Evan] Who's this?
I feel like these steps of Mexico
are a lot shorter than last time.
Fancy meeting you here.
Huh?
- Imagine this, meeting you here!
- [Evan] Isn't this where we,
haven't I seen you here before?
I feel like I've seen you here before.
It's a very special place for us.
- Oh, 'cause we met here.
- We met here, in Mexico.
Last year, we were here,
and I picked her up.
Oh, who's this?
Hello. (exclaims)
What's your name, huh?
Imagine meeting you, in a place like this.
(Nina chuckling)
I get to sit with Nina up front! (howls)
And who's behind us?
- The kids!
- Who's behind us?
Yeah.
(lively mid-tempo music)
What did we think of the ride, Hayden?
- [Hayden] Awesome!
- [Evan] Awesome?
- Now, we're going to run,
all the way to ice cream!
- [Evan] We're going to run to ice cream?
- [Hayden] Yeah!
- [Evan] We're going to run to ice cream.
I told the kids we can either go slowly,
and just go to the Figment ride,
or we can rush, and do ice
cream and Figment ride.
Guess what they wanted to do?
And we're rushed.
(groovy energetic music)
Nina's havin' some rum in
her coffee, in her ice cream.
Okay, don't get drunk, Nina.
- I probably will get drunk.
- [Evan] There she goes.
You know, that's not on the menu.
- Whoa.
- [Evan] Off the menu.
What do ya think?
Strong.
- Strong.
- [Evan] How's the ice cream?
- Yummy.
(Evan exclaiming)
- This is really, really good.
(exclaims) So good.
Nina's havin' a hard
time with the ice cream.
- It's so strong. (chuckles)
- [Evan] Okay?
You like your rum.
You're a rum-a-holic.
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Finish that up, drink it down!
- I can't, I can't--
- [Evan] Drink it down!
Okay, down it!
- Drink it slowly!
- [Evan] Chug, chug, chug!
That's off-the-menu stuff right there.
You got to do your research,
get some special service.
Yeah.
Suck it down, Nina!
Hello! (exclaims)
(laughs) It's amazing.
(light energetic music)
We've got Jeffrey up front!
We got me up front!
We got the three kids behind!
You excited?
- Yep!
- [Evan] Yo!
What'd ya think, guys?
- [Jeffrey and Stephanie] Good!
- [Evan] Hayden's still singing.
- Oh, is the ride done?
Oh, the ride's done.
- [Evan] What'd ya think?
- [Jeffrey] Awesome!
- Aright, next up, time to
watch some short films, yeah!
(mid-tempo relaxing music)
How was it?
- Fun!
It's cute.
- [Stephanie] Very funny!
- [Evan] Very funny?
Alright.
- It came down naked.
- [Evan] It came down naked.
The birds.
Alright, glad you enjoyed!
(mid-tempo relaxing music)
That's the end of day three for us!
Favorite ride?
- My favorite ride?
Is the future ride at Test Tracks.
- Test Track, Nina, favorite ride?
- (chuckles) I don't know.
- [Evan] Jeffery, favorite ride?
- Test Track.
- [Evan] Test Track.
My favorite ride
was watching Nina eat all
that ice cream alcohol.
That was great.
Alright, thank you guys, for joining us!
Day three!
We'll see you again, tomorrow!
Continue to believe!
And we'll see you soon!